Hi Michael.
>> Hey Charles. How you been?
>> I've been doing just fine. How've you been?
>> Good. It's been a while. I understand you went to Africa.
>> I went to Africa. The entire continent, or at least parts of it.
>> How's Africa?
>> It's fine. It's, warm.
>> The entire continent?
>> [LAUGH] The entire continent. Or at least Kenya and Nigeria.
>> Okay.
>> Particularly in Nigeria. Which was
80 something degrees and 4,000% humidity. [LAUGH]
>> So, do you want to do a shout
out to any of, any of your friends from there?
>> Yeah, I'd like to say hi to Chairman and I'd like to say hi
to Prof. Oh, and Good Times. I would like to say hi to Good Times. He
was awesome. Okay, so Michael. I am back now so that we can talk about the
last little section. That we're going to do in this class, and it's game theory.
>> That sounds cool. What does that have to do with machine learning?
>> So that's an interesting question because,
in fact, game theory comes from a tradition
way outside of machine learning in A.I. but you'll see
in a moment why it is I care about game
theory, and really this is a very natural extension to
all the stuff we've been talking about with reinforcement learning.
>> Interesting. Are we talking about games like Monopoly?
>> In some sense, we are. Because all of life is like
Monopoly. So in fact, what is game theory? Maybe that's what we can
do. We can just try to define game theory, and maybe it'll
be clear why it is we're worried about this at all. Seem fair?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.